okay great thanks a lot for the
introduction it's really really a
pleasure to be here I have the
great opportunity I guess of being of
participating in some of their
assignments programs in previous years
and its really nice learning not to be
back you know so the audience I think
it's like quite mix which is great we
have a nice mixture of experts in you
know making a lot of people that perhaps
I think they've all at least of the talk
is very much to mix with water in the
title right so first one I guess many of
you
[Music]
what exactly is water check I mean it's
very it's very global turn and we want
to see exactly what is optimization is
in general lacking many of you are
familiar with this don't you know I have
some function in there and I'm really
trying to find the best possible value
daikon right I try to write in there is
a point what your function achieves in
your body and optimize each what really
goes back you know maybe many many years
ago actually one player but one of the
earliest problems in Europe immunization
it is famous such as parametric problem
well it's something called diagnose
problem that really has to do with the
question of what is maximum surface that
you can you know you know that you can
survive but if you've never seen it
optimization began I think it's more
formal like once they know there were
studies but once we had the
I mean if way to talk about okay so once
we have or once we've had no a more
formal notion to talk about optimality
conditions and lino kind of that gave us
a very interesting and very insightful
connection for the instance with notions
of physics right whole variational
principles what's kind of interesting is
in recent years there was like all some
other notions that come into place
notions of complexity notions of
complexity and one of the things that's
so important and so interesting about
optimization is it not it's not an
isolated area of research but it has
pervasive connections with many many
areas blind of ranging from game theory
control theory combinatoric theoretical
computer science and number of other
areas you know the other thing that's
very interesting means it's not just a
mathematical question but also it's
really essential and ubiquitous about in
a number of scientific and engineering
domains right so in particular one of
the things that learned when we teach
optimization courses you always
emphasize that there's whole bunch of
industries right now industries today
that they're they just would not be
possible or they would be completely
different if they didn't have access to
optimization technology so in
particularly if you think about the way
that an airline is run now you know kind
of this is actually perfect optimization
enters pretty much in every single stage
of a pipeline when you think about how
do you design an engine when you think
about how do you simulate using
computational fluid dynamics when you
think how do you plant roots when you
think about how do you price how do you
schedule your crew
how do you do maintenance at all and
each one of these steps somehow
optimization enters in the picture
different flavors optimizations and
maybe more continuous some may be more
discrete but Leonor in the world over
the place you know this kind of things
and the same thing is true when you
think about finance and insurance every
financial product right now I know kind
of it's essentially the result of some
kind of fairly clever combination of
optimization and simulation ecommerce is
another example but really it's
it's a very a truly resource I guess of
a number of quite interesting industries
so when I talked about optimisation of
course I draw this cartoon I'm drawing
this cartoon in there of just a function
I'm trying to minimize so of course I
know recall all the details or the
difficulty of optimization problems they
come in terms of line how is this
function actually described what is the
allowable set of solutions and all those
considerations essentially give rise to
a very nice variety very rich and
incredibly rich variety of different
classes of optimization problems so this
picture this optimization tree or
optimization taxonomy for instance was
from the old version of a neo server or
somehow your nine or kind of have this
nice classification depending on few
look at continuous problems or discrete
problems by the way that's exactly the
first-order distinction in our Simons
program now I know we're trying to
essentially try to bring these two
things together and then lino can I mean
here you go in different branches
depending if you do integer stochastic
constraint whatever right and much of
this distinct nor many of these
extinctions really arise from starting
in the 1950s with the development of
linear programming and one of the things
I think researches in optimizations have
been doing is really producing more and
more classes of optimization problems
for which we can understand for instance
efficient algorithms or solving write
and again depending if you're more a
continuous person or a squid person a
complex person or a non convex person
you will find some hot line or something
in there right it's likely to to be
helped rotary right so one can discuss
and in fact people have discussed for a
long time which ones of all those
learning distinctions are perhaps the
most essential and there is a famous
quote I mean any value and does
optimization knows about Lane oven of
this very famous quote of Rockefeller
that says it's coming from this paper on
line of this nice review paper almost 25
years ago about Lagrange multipliers now
you know kind of trying to or or making
the point that really this big
distinction the big Watership in
optimization
determines somehow what flavors of tools
you would you should be using it's not
really about linear problems and
nonlinear problems which is very much
the traditional mindset right now and
how do you think about optimization but
it's really about convexity and non
convexity so one of the things I want to
explain a said learn off in the vanilla
bit why somehow this is a very sensible
thing to say I mean Rockefeller
certainly now you know knew exactly what
you are talking about but also that you
know kind of perhaps Larry knocking off
this is stinking it's a little bit less
sharp than we think that it may look at
the beginning and similarly the same is
true perhaps or many of these other
distinctions perhaps learn even if we
shouldn't really think about continuous
and discrete as being totally different
from each other programs or techniques
that you can apply from Lionel the
continuous or discrete and I know how we
can perhaps try to think at least some
aspects of all this complexity of
optimization probably some kind of nice
and unified way right so again hopefully
we have some idea of what I mean by
optimization so let me try to explain
again a little bit what this convexity
stuff is I know that learning organ at
least half of you are experts on this
but now I know enough let me at least
give you a lane or the the one slide
summary version of what is what is
convexity and why do we care about and
convexity again let me ignore equations
I don't care about the equations it's
really a very simple and very natural
property Waco opposite so it's a asset
or the property of a said being convex
is really knowing organda mode if you
have two points in your set whether the
whole line segments between your points
belong to the set so something like this
for instance is nice and complex if you
take any two points in the set the whole
line segment between leno x and y for
any x and y is going to be contained the
set button okay now something like this
set over here will not have this
property if you like equations that
equation is something like this but
again no it's really about the geometric
picture so there's a nice notion of
convexity not only for sets but also for
functions and again we can you can write
the definition this is the definition of
convexity or lambasting 0 1
perhaps if you understood the definition
for sets then the effusion for functions
is exactly the same or what we ask is at
the epigraph I mean the set of all the
function values above the graph of the
curve if this set is convex then we'll
say that the function is convex right so
somehow we really only need one
definition and I know even without any
theorems
it is perhaps clear why functions of
this type they're going to be nicer from
the optimization point of view that
functions of this type right more than
anything we'll learn there's many
reasons but let me just give you one
certainly because money whenever you
have a function of this type in any
local minimum in there is also going to
be global but whenever you have like a
know a function that looks like this and
the same properties not true right and
again one can quantify all of this and
one can one meet support enough like no
technical conditions for what I'm saying
to be exactly true
but generally speaking I know convex
optimization is a lot lot lot simpler
than generally on convex optimization I
don't this is perhaps some of the point
I'm trying to summarize in here why
complexity is so important and so
ubiquitous all over the place why it's
such a wonderful technology on the one
hand is the definition is extremely
simple
no I I just summarize it in one slide
I'm again I think there's a lot of
things that I think you can imagine that
are consequence of this but the
geometric the geometric properties is
geometric consequences of this are
actually extremely rich there's a lot of
consequences that come with this also
extremely important which I'm not saying
anything at all in this talk is that
this is also an incredibly powerful
modeling approach so it turns out that
learning are kind of most of the time in
practice we don't just write an
optimization problem and then we look at
it and then we say hey we happen to be
convex but actually the way that we with
models the way that you use parsers or
lonergan the war or modeling
environments they can be adapted or it
can be constrained in a way that only
convex optimization problems are going
to arise and in particularly in
engineering this has been enormously
powerful and enormously influential
learn all kind of this is I mean Steve
Boyd's notion of discipline convex
means they're not gonna fun very nice
way of formalizing this problem but also
there's very nice algorithmic
consequences right I mean again model or
some manual technicalities know in a
kind of we know the convex optimization
problems they can be solved for an
efficiently in theory and in practice
and the other thing of course is there's
been a lot of applications off so
somehow I mean it is really justify this
blowing oven of this notion that lie no
complex problems are very special and
very useful and we really want to
understand this it's certainly not gonna
be incredible but of course no no this
is very rough cut right just abiding the
world into convex and non convex then
Arghandab is perhaps in a bit
simplifying things so much lewis we do
know that there's not just one
distinction in there but that's actually
love by depending on who you talk to
they may tell you or now really they
know the most important difference in
the world
this is line organ of our things are
continuous or things of the screen
including some people in this audience
now you know some other people you know
will tell you know what really really
matters is where things have linear or
non-linear about you know kind of dyno
perhaps you know convexity or not but if
you have linear problems and renault
kind of all linear and underlying
functions and everything's tighter or
constrained but shall constrain I mean
there's a lot of like I said of all
these past possibilities and in fact I
told you about line again of this 93
that was in the old neo server line of
the new news server it actually has a
much more complicated taxonomy of line
okay and of all the different kinds of
optimization problems or run or kind of
you can classify them on whether you're
inserting deterministic dyno kind of
nonlinear equilibrium problem second or
con all kinds of new classifications
right and all of them are important line
all of those reasons why then I think
our optimization community has developed
the energy and of all these different
plants but really I mean let me be very
specific about this the you know kind of
all these extinctions all this
particular problem classes are extremely
important but really what I'm trying to
understand what I'm trying to at least
there's a single idea
to communicate today that really there's
quite a bit that we can do orders have
you know a fairly interesting circle of
ideas that we can try to use well at
least for a while
ignoring this extinct many of these
extinctions and this is what I'm really
trying I hope that I will convince you
that lion or Gandalf that really if at
least for a while we ignore Moreno kind
of all these subtleties or not so subtle
distinctions then perhaps you can do
interesting stuff so in the sense of
really asking is very noggin of all
these distinctions or watersheds very no
kind of are they real how sharp partner
I know is it really an issue that
learning or something is either convex
or non convex or I can think about
things in the middle do I really want to
think about something linear and
something nonlinear or I can put Dino
again make a finer gradation in there
and of course you know if you're
familiar with any aspects of mathematics
now you know that such things are often
very know kind of quite likely right
think about for instance even if you
think about an organ or some geometric
surface for instance you may think about
the linear case now you know kind of but
really if you're a little more
sophisticated you think okay really what
the linear case is somehow having
curvature equal to zero and then you may
think okay perhaps in situations that I
have small curvature I can think or do
something interesting or the same thing
if you like matrices you can think about
an invertible matrix right an invertible
or not invertible it's a short
distinction but again the more that you
know you think okay really what i should
care about this now how close to
invertible matrices right notions of
condition number for instance
similarly learning organ of if you know
we have a lot of TCS people in here if
you think about learning a polynomial
time versus exponential time line on
perhaps again that's a very rough
distinction and you may want to
introduce parameterized complexity
parameterized families of problems
learner kind of world you get Laennec
and some additional parameters in there
right so in a sense it's not a new
concept in this idea of course learn or
gain of of parliament or of now you know
giving sharper distinctions in there but
what I'm really interested is what
happens in the context of optimization
so chair
questions okay so now you know whether I
told you okay convex is great in all
kind of non convex is not great no so
now you know kind of perhaps one of the
simplest things that one can try to
think in fact one that's enormously
successful in many contexts is it try to
make things convex right so for instance
if I have let's imagine that my feasible
set is something like this I know just
it is connected set of points like it
happens in many combinatorial problems
then one thing that you may think about
it's okay let me try to take the convex
hull of the solutions so what is a
convex hull is really the smallest
convex set that contains all the points
in the original set the nice operation
that will take any set and it will
return you like you know the best convex
approximation if you want are you
haven't said anything all computability
but certainly it's a geometric operation
that we can do with my set and similarly
with a function if you have a function
which is not convex then I may think
about what is a nicest convex function
or the closest convex function to my
given function and this is what's called
usually the convex envelope of my
function these are great things now you
know kind of it's perhaps and among the
first things that you can try that you
should try whenever you're faced with a
problem if you can compute this ones but
it has some cons glory noggin the world
or some difficulties in the
applicability of this the main one is a
typically obtaining descriptions of this
may be very difficult although in
principle it's easy to say the convex
hull is the smallest convex set that
contains your points then long enough
you may not be able to write to explain
this to your computer you may not be
able to write some nice description of
this complex hull that you can use it
and of course if you're a community
optimization person you know that this
is always the case right on the other
hand depending on what kind of furniture
you're interested in you made loss
information right so if in here I look
at the convex hull of the solutions
somehow really the compacts hell doesn't
it forget about all these points in
interior right so I don't have perhaps
if i optimize an arbitrary function over
my set then I know kind of it may forget
or in I may not keep track of learning
or kind of the information in that
so somehow for some things computing
convex hulls is not even if I you could
it would not be the right thing right so
the question is what can we do know in
our kind of this is one way in which you
can take an organ of some problem
perhaps communitarian perhaps our you
know kind of non convex or whatever line
of you know one produce some kind of
nice complex forms because these are
there are alternatives or the rather
ways that you can draw it or produce
product and one of the insights I mean a
very all the insight is that really
sometimes it's just a matter of how you
think about the product right that
learner can have in a certain sense that
one can make very very precise pretty
much any set of any problem you can
really think about it directly as as a
complex problem perhaps in a very large
I mentioned perhaps even an infinite
dimension but there's a very natural way
in which I can think about learning or
kind of a set in any space as being
associated to do a convex set so let me
try to make let me describe it first and
let me give a couple of examples so
conceptual is quite easy so essentially
what I could do is I could think about
myself in convex or every point in my
set is actually giving me a new
dimension right so think let's think
about the case where I have a finite set
in here I just have four points over
there and then what I'm going to do is
instead I'm going to associate this set
if you want with a simplex in four
dimensional space where every extreme
point every corner in here corresponds
exactly to my point down starts right so
if I have a finite set of points in our
take whatever K happens to be but I have
n points I'm really going to associate
it to this an N dimensional simplex will
end in here may be very very large right
on the other hand if I have a continuous
set think about in here having some line
or kind of complicated set which is
continuous then I'm going to associate
with the simplex but in an infinite
dimensional space right so think about
the exactly same picture no in Orono but
now with an infinite number of corners
of course that doesn't make much sense
so this is non exactly same thing I said
gimme comics he'll let me emphasizes
missing here my sad lives in r2 if I
want to take the convex hull this convex
hull would live in r2 but this set in
here is living upstairs in a very in a
large I mentioned space but what is true
that's actually very interesting is that
there's an if by ejection or there's a
correspondence if you want between the
extreme points in here and the points
answers so this construction you know
about it there's many many many
different ways of thinking about what's
happening in here depending what your
background is one let me give you three
or perhaps for now you know one is
certainly instead of thinking about my
set I think about the space of priority
distributions on my set right when you
think about it what am i doing the
distributions of my four points are
exactly associated with the simplex in
four dimensional space if my set is more
complicated then line or Gandalf I would
have to think about distributions on
myself but the point is that naturally
has some nice convexity structure the
same thing is true now you know if you
think about another way of thinking
about this is that you go to a
functional space you're thinking of the
space of functions on your set and again
there's going to be some natural linear
structure in there are convex virtually
there if you've ever seen anything about
games that's of course if the idea that
we can go to mix strategies in a game we
can randomize over actions and now you
get nice dialogue enough like a much
nicer structure in control fear is
something called relaxed controlling and
depending on which part of the world
you're coming from I'm pretty sure
you've seen some versions of this in one
form or the other and by the way I told
you like no this is not just about
convex or non convex exactly same thing
is true when you think about the
distinction that we think in
differential equations or controls or
physics between linear processes and
nonlinear processes
exactly same thing is true when you
write not the dynamics of your system
but you write the dynamics or for
instance party distributions on your on
your state space on your face space what
then you will equation if you know what
that is or fokker-planck or aluminum any
of the classical equations in
practically right now kind of once you
go to priority space long enough then in
that case everything becomes nice and Li
by the way every I think many of you
have heard for instance people saying
quantum mechanics is linear
I know regardless of anything this is
exactly what one means when you want to
talk about the linearity of quantum
mechanics its linearity in in phase
space again this is perhaps not very
important like we don't want to do
focuses his picture quite at very noggin
of there's at least a very formal
processor we can take any set and lift
it or think about in some kind of line
of thing in some infinite dimensional
space and this is great now you know
it's the kind of things that learn all
kind of I think when you're in grad
school you think about the goo it blows
your mind let me know kind of blood line
no kind of when you really go into the
details this is not the real practical I
mean often write this again doing things
in some infinite dimensional space right
now you know it may not be there you
know very useful and less of some
structure up there
now the question the real question that
I want to discuss today is can you get a
way other situations what you can get
away not just with an infinite
dimensional space like before but with a
finite or even small dimension this is
really what I'm asking if I start with
some non convex having here I know that
if I go to infinite dimensional space
and there are some one to be some nice
complexity structure but I know that's
not a real useful that what else can I
get away with final image and hopefully
smile I can I come back safai things in
some way so let me give an example now
you know that basis is not like a crazy
idea it's a very simple example what for
instance learning not going to might
take a non convex set that's my doughnut
the donut I ate this morning actually
bagel I ate a bagel no it dont
and this is defined by these quadratic
inequalities is set in the plane defined
exactly by this quadratic inequalities
and obviously it's a non convex set its
program some of the simplest non convex
sets
you can try them again let me remind you
to take any two points I'd look at the
line segment and of course it's not
contained in there so let's imagine that
I'm trying to solve some kind of problem
over this set know in organo one clearly
I shouldn't be able to use convex
optimization BC says it's just not
complex now what I claim is that there
is a way of essentially taking this set
and lifting it to some nice I mention
space r3 in such a way that learning all
kind of it will be nice and complex so
the map that I want to use a very simple
map in this case I'm just going to take
x + y 2 X Y and X 4 + y square so
essentially what I'm doing is I'm taking
the plane in here and I'm mapping it
into the surface of this paraboloid over
here so there's a nice map or it takes
any point in there and it goes up there
into some point and I want you to know
this what happens right I want you to
think in here not of the surface in
there but actually of the convex body
that I could obtain if I fill this in
and I slice it with these two
hyperplanes right so this is filled with
water right now can the by slicing in
here and I slice it in here
so I get like a nice barrel like thank
and notice something wonderful that
happens every point downstairs is a
projection of an extreme point of this
compact set I can't really define the
extreme point extreme point really means
something that's not going on the
boundary it's not a complex combination
of other things right so something
wonderful happens if I optimize over
here over this nice compact set defined
by these inequalities any linear
function the minimizer downstairs is
going to give me a point in my bakery
either right so really instead of
solving like a bad non convex problem
down here I can just solve now you know
some nice convex problem over this
convex so natural question what is going
on where did I get this map from knowing
organda one
right now kind of how we can use this
anymore in the better and more
interesting way but it's a phenomenon
clear what's happening in here if not
questions would be great no questions
good okay so really know in organic food
I'm talking about I told you before the
drain of enough we started an arbitrary
set down there and there's always a way
of Larry not producing this way no kind
of thing up in the you know kind of in
ideally infinite dimensional space
whatever Larry know kind of or
everything is nice and wonderful but
we're never going to get there right so
the question is a drain or other things
that you can do in the middle in there
can you produce somehow not just finite
dimension but hopefully small mappings
in there
with this property so in particular what
they want to understand and develop are
systematic and efficient ways of doing
this in here this construction with
extremely ad hoc line I just wrote this
but the question is again no no enough
how could what go and write this in a
more systematic way without going all
the way to infinity under the technology
for this line or something called
hierarchies of relaxations and I what I
really want to do is to at least explain
the basic ideas of why such things are
even possible
yep so something in here when you
optimize any linear function no no any
linear function up here this will always
be on the boundary of this cell so the
point is remember that I really want to
optimize some function in here so the
point is you can you can rewrite any
nonlinear function in here as a linear
function up here again in this case
there are some restrictions but in the
general setting any function that you
will drive in here it will become a
linear function in the space yeah it's a
great question good so okay I mention
the words hierarchies learnig enough in
the academic field or whatever there's
lots of
lots of hierarchies depending on who you
are all kind of you know you may worry
about later on comparisons between
different academic fields or come anyway
no you know if there's a lot of
interesting things about this but what
it is I mean of course hierarchies have
a very very long history in optimization
right Larry no kind of this is not
somehow in a new notion in different
forms although there's a lot of learning
or somehow things that we understand I
think a lot better that it's there are
very classical constructions in integer
programming when you start with integer
programs and you produce families of
linear programs that will have
essentially these kind of features but
in particular what I want to focus on is
perhaps like I think it's for the same
is one of the most powerful ways that we
have of producing this kind of
hierarchies that really are based on
these notions of samos courses trying to
explain a little bit why something like
this will appear in here and also why
somehow this is all going to rely on
something called semi definite perfect
right it is a very interesting class of
convex problems so I'll explain I'll
come back exactly from this but again at
the high level and there's many
different ways of interpreting what
we're really trying to do is to produce
a parameterized family just hide in here
of of approximations to my convex body
perhaps in higher and higher dimensional
spaces so I mentioned in here this funny
word
semi definite problems on semi definite
programming you know let me at least
leave a picture I think if you've never
seen semi definite programming it may
help at least to get into the right
class if you've seen some I definite on
me if you know what semi definite
promise learning or kind of been I think
this geometric picture may actually help
you also
so what is a semi definite erm is a very
very nice generalization of these class
of problems called linear problems which
are essentially optimization problems of
define over polyhedral sets with finally
main inequalities to the case of the
feasible set is now the intersection of
a subspace and the cone of positive
semi-definite matrices so these are
symmetric matrices which are possible
semi definite that is SN plus and I'm
intersecting this set with a subspace
and what I'm trying to do is to optimize
a linear function over that intersection
this looks like a crazy thing to do now
you know but it
so that no it's a wonderful and
incredibly powerful family of complex
optimization problems let me just make a
couple of observations first of all this
includes linear programming as a very
particular case when you restrict to the
case of just diagonal matrices right the
diagonal matrix is possible semi
definite only if the noggin of all the
elements are non-negative
but in particular what's nice about it
is that somehow it says canonical a
class of problems as one may hope for
there's a beautiful duality theory it's
convex and final dimensional we have
wonderful algorithms to solve this and
the you know kind of model or some minor
technicality said things are solvable in
polynomial time so this is a and
underlying I'm really going to use this
kind of as a black box but there's a lot
of random and incredibly variety of
problems learn or get about cross no in
all kind of you know engineering and
science and math and whatever that are
reducible to this form even though in
principle they may look nothing like
this so if you want to learn one thing I
would recommend strongly to learn oh
what's maybe probably so I told you
about you know kind of somehow these
notions of you know kind of or trying to
construct these kind of maps although
you know kind of all these families of
hierarchies that people have built and
the way I'd like to think it somewhat
perhaps not very nice
is that really what what you do is
you're building a machine right whatever
the hierarchies it's really a machine
that will take the in organ of your
non-convex problem some non convex
formulation in there it has enough in
there that will allow you to say how
much you're lifting and in the end
what's going to come is some complex
optimization problem exactly some semi
definite product right so what people
have done is essentially build better
and better machines over there and one
of the things that I want to explain
this perhaps one of the nicest ones that
we have this one over here and why
somehow it's fairly canonical it's
really difficult I think or we don't
know ways of building I think things are
better than this kind of machines I will
tell you a little bit what's the
evidence that perhaps not in organ of
these machines are optimal
in some particular sense so remember
what I told you what we were doing
before in my example about the de bacon
I was taking any point down stir any
point all points on stands and I was
mapping them upstairs so it turns out
the glowing organ of the way that this
relaxation spark is they take a very
nice map a very nice canonical map to
take any point downstairs and map it
upstairs and what they do is they take a
point X and in mapping into the
symmetric tensor product of X K times
right and this is what we denote by best
if you've never seen or you don't quite
know what this is really think about
taking any point X I form all the
monomials of degree K in the variables X
Y and that's exactly you know the end of
were my pointed map by the way if you're
a machine learning person and I think
all of us are apparently learning of in
recent times think of all this is very
much like now you know kind of like a
polynomial kernel I mean this is doing
something very very similar to what the
polynomial kernel is doing the Anoka or
the feature map associated to the
polynomial kernel it's essentially very
very similar what's kind of interesting
like in my picture is that not only you
need to map things upstairs but you also
need to understand hopefully the convex
hull of the image of your points right
like all the way back in my example I
was taking my donut in my bagel I was
mapping it upstairs and in this case I
have a nice description of the image of
the donut under of the bagel under this
map right I can write more or less
explicit inequalities for this region
and it turns out that they essentially
this is my condition B if you want I
want to be able to effectively describe
what this approximate this convex hull
of the image so this looks like a crazy
problem how would you do this but when
you really think about what I was
showing before I was mapping Marino kind
of my points through this tensor product
and then I take a linear function in
here that's worth taking the convex hull
means and trying to understand all the
inequalities of are valid in this object
and a linear functional and the tensor
product is nothing but a polynomial
right so what we're really trying to
understand is whether for any linear
function this polynomial is actually
non-negative that means exactly that
whether the set is contained the image
of myself it's contained on the heart
space associated to the point so what do
we need to do we need to understand
again we're reducing it to perhaps a
more complicated problem but we really
need to understand this notion of non
negativity when the polynomial in
several variables is non-negative and by
the way before telling you how I know
how this is done let me mention that
this problem understanding the convex
hull of a set is a really really
important and ubiquitous problem liner
when I'm in many areas right I mean of
course in combinatorial optimization
with this is a bread and butter of
trying to understand Leno kind of the
different algorithms but exactly same
thing is true for instance when you look
at other objects not just convex hulls
of finite set of points like in the
combinatorial case but for instance
right now if you're trying to understand
the convex hull of an algebra variety
the compacts hull of a point and there
is group action the convex hull of line
or kind of some curve and the group
action there's a lot of situations or
somehow this is really what the object
that one is trying to understand the
convex hull of something and understand
depending on who you are may mean very
different things
it may mean computationally it may mean
geometrically I want to understand I
know the structure of the equations that
define it it may mean I know I'll try
Kaleem
again depending who you are
understanding may mean very different
things okay so let me go back learn or
kind of to what's happening over here I
told you hopefully you believe me that
if I am that once I take my set I map it
in here with my map feed and I'm trying
to understand linear inequalities up
here that the same thing as
understanding polynomial inequalities
down there and again if you're a kernel
person you know exactly what I'm talking
about
but
then what are we going to do I mean I
need to understand other sample
denomination on negative perhaps a
simplest and obvious things that I can
try to do is try to say okay if my
polynomial is a sum of squares of some
other polynomials it certainly this is
going to trivial imply that p is
non-negative that's a whole bunch of
things that one can say about this but
the only thing that we care in here is
that this is an obvious sufficient
condition for P being non negative and
in particular this condition is going to
be computable or reducible to semi
definite programming so when I put these
two observations together really what
that means is a following but the way
that this constructions work is exactly
by the disk combination of taking point
semesters and mapping them with a
feature map or a polynomial map like
you're usually exactly this Baronessa
map the symmetric tensor product and
then what you do is you replace a notion
of a convex hull which is looking at all
the valleys inequalities on your set by
all the value inequalities that you can
prove using a somewhat scores a
composition and this is all that's going
on in here now you know these conditions
for simple reasons they become better
and better with fixed scalar is strictly
contained in each other and for every
fixed K these are polynomial time
sources the dimension of the space is
actually all relevant and under very
mild conditions what this will give you
is exactly that these hierarchies are
complete that in the finite case after
finitely many steps you actually
converge to the convex hull or two to
the feasible set that you want in the
infinite case you will have asymptotic
convergence and again I would not
concern in here about the details of how
this works but the point is I know this
actually realizes exactly this picture
or this promise that we wanted of loreno
kind of giving us a gradation or of
moving between lying on my original non
convex or discrete or whatever you want
to think about set
downstairs all the way up we have
Lanigan of this infinite dimensional
space whenever things wonderful and
lying on will live forever
and learn organum in the meantime for
any fixed K learn organ of we have
better and better approximations and
sometimes or often even very small
values of K may be sufficient right so
yeah let me summarize perhaps at this
point some of the things are going on
really all these hierarchies pieces gave
us an explicit way of trading off how
much convexity do you want versus how
much are you willing to enlarge did i
mention of your part we know what I told
you before if I don't care about
dimension dimension goes to infinity
then we'll get convexity for free on the
other hand when the dimension is small
my problem may not be convex but there's
a trade-off in there right and
hierarchies gives us one way they give
us one way of not realizing this trader
of course this is just talk
we need theorems that will show that all
I'm saying is true under they will
quantify exactly how much we gain and we
lose and this is absolutely possible to
do
we've done it people have done this but
the result may depend on specific
problem classes right for some problem
classes this is great you gain a lot for
some other problem classes it seems that
you don't gain a lot on the other hand
we don't know anything that does it any
better and this is the other point that
I want to emphasize you sometimes it's a
little bit confusing that when we again
I gave you four like this list of lorina
kind of a thing you know six or seven
hierarchies or hired machines that
people have developed and when you think
about what makes one good or bad right I
mean never focus on just convergence but
I know after so many steps whatever you
get the right because usually those
results are not in organ of somehow
there's nothing interesting that goes on
in there they know what's what in what's
really important is to understand learn
organ of either quantitative results
that will quantify exactly this kind of
trade-offs or empirical results one of a
very surprising part of an organ of this
whole sum of course machinery in
particular suppose some of the other
ones is that really it works
very very well in practice for
relatively small values of K we knew
from before many hierarchies that will
work learning with exactly same kind of
theoretical properties in the sense of
asymptotes literally converge but what
was what was very interesting
what is very surprising is how well they
perform even for relatively small values
of K and again I will not say too much
about this okay I have like five minutes
I need to wrap up so there's been a lot
of applications no no no I will not
spend time discussing any of them in
detail but really not pretty much if you
have any problem in whatever domain it
is no you know kind of a ton polynomials
have involved I strongly suggest that
you at least try to see what are these
techniques and actually help you or not
those problems have at least on the
surface they don't look at all like lino
these techniques may be useful like
things that have to do with quantum
information or things that have to fluid
dynamics and it turns out that you can
do very very interesting things or
robotics and you can do lino very
interesting things using this kind of
machinery the other thing and this is
also I want to point out to some of the
things are going on at assignments at
the in based on knowing okay now is
really trying to understand a little bit
more the gap I mean or if there is a gap
between theory and parties one of the
things as I mentioned that's very
interesting of this kind of things is
that they're extremely good
asymptotically innocent opiod Ino kind
of the kind of regime were line of
people in in theoretical computer
science usually work I don't care about
the actual practical efficiency of an
algorithms I care there is no most of a
time and other synthetic properties but
also they're kind of extremely good for
many problems that involve a reasonable
number of other words it's very
interesting for reasons that I don't
think we fully understand why these kind
of things will be working well at both
ends of the spectrum
people are actually using this in
practice if you actually want to solve I
know you want to make your robot walk
some of my colleagues and MIT are
actually using this kind of technology
in order to understand learn all kind of
how line open if you come you compute
controllers
line or for 904 to stabilize a robot on
the other hand I know many of my
colleagues at the theoretical computer
science are actually very
like here they're trying to understand
what are the limits of these kind of
machineries
let me also mention Nova dragon I don't
have a lot a lot of time to say some in
your practice that a big part in here
what I described is of course only the
tip of the iceberg right there's a lot
of water that goes on when you're given
a problem you don't just take it at face
value but you really try to explore it
as much structure as as possible right
and there's a lot of work and there's a
lot of lion-o kind of the special
techniques that will allow us to learn
you're giving the optimization problem
or given learn or kind of some family of
polynomials you want to understand what
is the structure of these polynomials
symmetry properties sparsity properties
dialogue and of what we define I mean
there's a lot of technology that will
allow us to not write the obvious my
definite porn that you will write but to
do some things in a very clever and
smart way right and again I don't have a
time at all to discuss this but now
you're gonna think about it and
everything that I described as a very
rough first cut of what's actually going
on underneath also there's a lot of
incredibly interesting and enormous
assimilating connections with
mathematics I mean with lion or Gandalf
with many many areas of mathematics I
haven't I mentioned I guess the tip of
the iceberg of these connections with
probability when you think about the
things as though in all kind of just
polity distributions but in particular
line or some very foundational results
in probability things like the
exchangeability theorem the definite is
exchangeability rom they can't be
understood very much in the same lines
of what's happening in here I guess I
totally read about quantum but no in a
kind of those very nice non non
commutative analog of all the story when
instead of thinking about polynomials in
commutative variables you think about
polynomials in non commutative variables
does an assisted geometry with it I'm
into it and I know kind of all these
techniques are actually quite useful in
that regard
again I can't really say a lot so in the
two minutes I have left let me say a
little bit about what are the kind of
things that people are trying to
understand now now you know again there
were a lot of it and actually we have
doing a shameless advertisement for an
ergonomic wardrobe that's what is
happening at the Simons
I think in
so couple of months so there on the one
hand there's a lot of interest in trying
to understand other limits of these
machines what are the limits of this
failure case what can they prove what
they what they cannot prove right then
there's been both very interesting
positive results and very interesting
negative results of course I will not
solve NP hard problems but it really
looks like no inorg enough that at least
for a very large class of statistical
problems we don't really have any
algorithms that are any better than this
that this is in a sense and people like
boswellia Cobb conjecture that one organ
of this essentially an optimal algorithm
in a sense that one can make quite
precise if something a number a more
positive and constructive person rather
than computational complexity people
that are on the complexity person trying
to prove negative results I I really
want to understand okay I want produce
better machines under C - of course very
enormous interesting results will tell
us that at least in some generality like
no there's no better machines but in for
particular problems we can do things
better know in organ the one again I
don't have time to discusses but if you
come to the workshop you may you may
hear a little bit about it on the
practical side like I said this is
absolutely wonderful when it works the
problem the real problem in practice is
that this NCP's get very big very
quickly we have any experience with semi
definite programming you know that
solving large semi definite problems is
complicated not just me not so much
because I they take a long time but
really because of memory issues and I
know one of the things that people are
trying to understand algorithmic side
much of work again by people here at the
Simon's is trying to understand
algorithms that perhaps achieve the same
kind of guarantees in some in some
situations but they're cheaper to run
the particular cells and an example of
this nice spectral algorithms or perhaps
idea would be to still solve these many
different problems and give up
complexity do I not going to try to do
something perhaps quick and dirty and
low you know kinda man I think it will
be very interesting if somehow this
program will succeed and I think one of
the things that I can at least I'm
particularly interested it's a drawing
or in the father we can get algorithms
that are
I think better than the great technology
that we have based on interior points
but at the same time they're still
practical I mean they don't just work in
the synthetic limit my second and last
shameless advertising if you want to
know about all this stuff that's a nice
book that we created with Gregg and
Rekha you can get it right now you can
just download it I'm not selling
anything
now you know kind of and yeah so you can
just go there no you know kind of and I
think that's it thanks
[Applause]
so it so the question is what is
reasonable right so I think a lot of it
depends on structure right there right
like no counting variable somehow it's
not really the right thing I mean if you
don't put any structure whatsoever I so
I assume things are absolutely dance now
in others then line